stand accuse the worst goddamn mystery
on the adulteress mmm
you
ah greetings you bad [ __ ] uncle
Joey here it's a beautiful day to be
alive the clouds around the birds ain't
singing but it really doesn't matter cuz
the love in your heart over tanks over
these [ __ ] clouds uncle Joey I know
it's late I had a doctor's appointment
late thirty
I'm hip hop Magoo my wrist is [ __ ] up
everything is [ __ ] up but you know
what uncle Joey's still [ __ ] taken but
listen we didn't [ __ ] come here to
chitchat about my health we came here to
blow some [ __ ] bones here I got a
couple different weeds to hang out this
Vigi neck I got this [ __ ] chunks
choice tremendous and I got this debt
from [ __ ] buds and roses [ __ ] it's
called tighten like the [ __ ] Remember
the Titans like people white people
who's having a good time smoking dope
okay I suggest you do the same
[Music]
tremendous justjust utterly [ __ ]
tremendous I love getting high were you
[ __ ] savages in the morning loosen up
I got a big day no jujitsu today I got
[ __ ] meetings and writing meetings
and [ __ ] more meetings now I got a
spot tonight you're not doing nothing
come on down the dark horse alone 507
Reseda Boulevard right off the [ __ ]
101 we get there by 9:00 we got some
muscles we do some [ __ ] jokes who
knows who's gonna show up time as long
as you show up that's all the [ __ ]
mess
but Joey enough with the chitty-chat
that smoke that [ __ ] tight must let
the spirits loose let's let the pigeons
newsome gank cuz you know me we gotta
get [ __ ] started early I was out here
boiling [ __ ] bones at 6:05 in the
a.m. so low like forbidden
this [ __ ] Titan is so good it looks
beautiful it smells beautiful
it tastes beautiful what do you guys
don't say sometimes we all comes [ __ ]
together and it all works out there's
this [ __ ] that [ __ ] Hillary Clinton
smoked when she got all dizzy and [ __ ]
this is the [ __ ] right here jerk you
know we show up with a heavy duty boy
all the [ __ ] time because you know
I'm not gonna show up with some [ __ ]
fool gazing at my buddy's house
this combination is shish-kabob
[ __ ] poker here nice you see
everybody's happy this [ __ ] booze
look at this [ __ ] you probably can't
[ __ ] it goes from here to [ __ ]
here look at the black and blue there we
are
jiu-jitsu [ __ ] one day John one days
you [ __ ] nut sack
you gotta keep going it's like life who
gives a [ __ ] it's just a bump in the
road you know Sam
people confuse a bump in the road with
like [ __ ] a disaster now it's just a
bump in the road you figure out you go
around no big [ __ ] deal you [ __ ]
dummies
she she collapsed she didn't collapse
she's [ __ ] old she's got like ants in
the [ __ ]
and it's old before you understand me
stop with the [ __ ] excuses she she
she collapsed
that's what see an ontology you dumb
[ __ ] and you believe it you believe
everything that guy he collapsed what do
you think she collapsed on me with
people [ __ ] collapse you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Jimenez I love smoking reefer I
love the smell of it what [ __ ] coffee
coffees for these [ __ ] Gentiles they
but a Starbucks I think they doing
something different
take a suck my dick meanwhile Cuban
coffee 50 cents a company up for [ __ ]
three days jet down way of life they
could all suck my dick I'm a whole
street Jew from [ __ ] is really
understanding [ __ ] around via Cuba with
the yarmulke on shabbat shalom a [ __ ]
around
see this this is what it's all about
people you can't do this and get
date-time then you're living in
communism this is what it's all about
if you can't pop outside your [ __ ]
work and do it too little too loose and
get tuned up its communist think about
it [ __ ] communist my mother swam be
is gonna have to [ __ ] calm you nice
with these [ __ ] now I gotta
come here and do what everybody else
does and say whatever else is where
whatever the hell says get the [ __ ] out
of here a nation of [ __ ] people will
look like one another it's easy for Isis
to shoot us
tomorrow 8:00 p.m. the podcast the
church what's happening now bigger
better and blacker you understand me
today I got other [ __ ] to do I gotta
write I gotta figure out what they do is
kind of [ __ ] exercises maybe a lot of
jujitsu train just do [ __ ] drills for
an hour you know you gotta bring this
[ __ ] fat off one way I know it just
cuz you're here you can still do shut up
stick your [ __ ] that's what I did
this month there's like [ __ ] a
hundred sit-ups oh yeah there's some
helicopters district' without my abs and
their low breathing exercises I held it
that dang for [ __ ] bas Rutten he was
talking about Rogan to get your lungs in
better shape come on dawg
every day you gotta be better than the
day before
and if you don't know that nobody told
you Yong chol Joe is telling you right
now you gotta be better today than what
you were yesterday and tomorrow you got
to be better than what came from you or
today that's what life is all about if
you're gonna do that
go [ __ ] yourself not gonna work out feet
one more bolt then I gotta go inside
I got Barbra Streisand I'm serious I'm
gonna hang out with Babs all [ __ ]
morning and get that State of Mind
switch to another [ __ ] again tighten
blood and roses bud and roses [ __ ]
tremendous what the [ __ ] - suck it dick
you hang out with Uncle Joe you see lots
of [ __ ] week once a week I'm sorry I
got emotional I'm the adulteress and
pretend this [ __ ] - this morning when
I got in if you haven't listened to the
[ __ ] pretenders in years it's time
for you to put them back on Chrissie
Hynde Shh [ __ ] is not [ __ ] around
but anyway Joey what's with the music
chick Jen let's spark his a little back
to the side I'm on the [ __ ] clock on
Union time you think you're one of those
dancers from Telemundo in on union hit
just dance a [ __ ] 12 hours
not one word
deep and that's it comes up as you know
I love you I'll be in Austin Texas
Thursday Friday Saturday one on the
street it's already sold out and I'm in
New York next week Friday and Saturday
for shows if you haven't got your
tickets forgot them
you [ __ ] slippin cuz I'm [ __ ]
coming up to this that's my backyard
Austin Texas is my backyard I cut my
peat in [ __ ] Texas income I was
always either in El Paso snorting blah
blah and Houston snorting blow and New
York come on I know I like the back of
my [ __ ] hand I'm gonna come out like
[ __ ] possessed
that's it
well that's that I'll catch you
[ __ ] later on the flipside you
know I love you all my life
walk that listen tell them all to suck
your dick because at the end when you
land in a casket we're gonna be thinking
about those times I've been thinking
about these [ __ ] you [ __ ] like
give them a [ __ ] shoes back anyway
I love you stay black have a good day
don't take [ __ ] from nobody do your
push-ups alright stay black with Joey
loves you